comic books aren't known for shying away
from strange subject matter but over the
years Marvel has managed to whip up a
few moments that went further than we'd
ever thought possible some of these
events caused major controversies while
others flew below the radar but all of
them haunted us well after we put the
comics down here's what a small sampling
of some of the most disturbing moments
in Marvel Comics
spider-man's sins past the amazing
spider-man sins past storyline is a
troubling poorly plotted tale that
defies continuity and outright poisons
spider-man's timeline the story is
disturbing on many levels
first there's the very creepily draw an
image of Norman Osborn having an adult
encounter with Gwen Stacy
spider-man's first love seriously nobody
wants to see that Marvel that was
followed up by a ridiculous secret
pregnancy and rapidly aging genetically
modified twins dead set on murdering
Peter Parker arguing that spider-man
sins past is one of the worst comics of
the 2000s one comic book critic noted
that the series reads almost like a
mash-up of every bad idea in comics
storied history
ouch carnage is power drill the origin
story of carnage is one of the darkest
in Marvel Comics history the boy who
grows up to be the classic bad guy
murders his grandmother by pushing her
down the stairs next he sets his sights
on man's best friend his foster parents
dog the poor pup was healthy happy and
trusting and kid carnage chose to
torment it with a power drill even
considering all the other terrible
things he's done over the years that
one's definitely one of the cringe iasts
hank pym is domestic cruelty for most of
his life in comics dr. Henry Pym aka
ant-man aka a giant man aka a Goliath
aka Yellow Jacket aka wasp has made some
pretty bad decisions
like for instance is inability to stick
to one superhero identity or perhaps
that time he accidentally created Ultron
but more than anything else
Hank Pym is known for his unhealthy
relationship with Janet Van Dyne the
original wasp which came to a head in
1981 s Avengers number 212 during an
argument Pym punches Janet and knocks
her across a room Pym was booted from
the Avengers but that incident remains
one of the most controversial moments in
Marvel history and it continues to color
fans
reception of hank pym to this day
twincest in ultimates needless to say
those are just some examples of the
insanity that went down in Marvel's many
years of comic books so by the early
2000s Marvel tried to simplify things
and update its characters with the
launch of the ultimate marvel line of
comics and the ultimate version of The
Avengers were simply called The
Ultimates The Ultimates book was often
blunt and brutal tackling everything
from a leaked tape of a cinematic no
pants party between Black Widow and Tony
Stark to 3d printed clones of Earth's
Mightiest Heroes but that doesn't hold a
candle to swinging on the family tree in
the third ultimate series Quicksilver
and Scarlet Witch who are brother and
sister get down to bedtime business in
the woods while Wolverine watches from
the bushes yikes Ultimates three should
have been the worst of it
but then came ultimatum ultimatums gross
weird massacre after a few years the
Ultimate Marvel Universe was just as
confusing as the regular one so Marvel
published a miniseries called ultimatum
to try to tidy it up but all it really
did was sweep the old mess into a corner
and dump more dirt all over the floor in
this event series magneto flips the
magnetic poles of the earth wreaking
havoc and causing the deaths of millions
of people and if that weren't bad enough
the bad guy known as blob straight-up
eats the wasps innards then in a fit of
revenge giant man turns around and chops
off the blobs head and the horror show
doesn't stop there magneto uses Iron Man
suit and cyclopses powers to obliterate
Wolverine then Cyclops blows Magneto's
head off with his eye beams to go along
with those disgustingly brutal deaths
ultimatum also wiped out enough fan
favorites on and off panel in a
bloodbath that would have put the Game
of Thrones red wedding scene to shame
Punisher steamrolls Wolverine from
brother-sister love to power drilled
pooches you'd think there wouldn't be
too many lines left for Marvel comics
across but then that means you probably
forgot about the Punisher when writer
Garth Ennis reinvented the Punisher
franchise for Marvel nights and Punisher
max he left Frank Castle with a new
death-dealing life in fact there's a
moment that stayed with readers for a
long time
in to issues of the Punisher from 2001
our hero gets into a fight with
Wolverine and uses a shotgun to blast
the skin and soft-tissue of Wolverines
face shoots him between the legs but you
know where and runs him over with a
steamroller
Austin power style
when he's done The Punisher parks the
thing on top of Wolverines crushed frame
which actually isn't really disturbing
so much as it's completely hilarious
yeah that seems about right thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our youtube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]